[Música]
há uns dois meses atrás eu conheci um
vaso sanitário onde a gente faz as
nossas necessidades
esse vaso sanitário ele faz uma análise
físico química dos nossos projetos e
forma geladeira
o que a gente pode comer a nova de comum
entre 37 e na sequência de um filme em
que se mostrava uma pessoa no seu
banheiro com a quantidade nome de tubos
poemas diferentes oferece o que essa
pessoa a função que ela queria comer
naquele dia ela jogava no vasco para que
o vasco por fornecer informações para
geladeira deseja deixar essa pessoa
comer aquilo que ela quer aquilo que ela
queria comer
são evoluções como essas é um negócio
desses objectivos como esses estão
chegando a cada vez mais criando
mudanças significativas nas nossas vidas
e muito mais ainda está por vir como por
exemplo as lentes de contato e
inteligentes que vão permitir um piscar
de olhos que evidente que quem com quem
a gente está falando achar informações
por exemplo pílulas ou comprimento
inteligentes podem vai ter laboratórios
dentro dessas pelo descumprimento
quando a gente em polícias o primeiro
permite tirar fotos em identificar
células cancerígenas e muita coisa mas
por exemplo nós vamos ser capazes de
imprimir na nossa própria casa e
customizar produtos e serviços
então esse tipo de mudança está cada vez
mais presente cada vez mais e mais veloz
e vai mudar significativamente as nossas
vidas
só para você ter uma idéia estima-se que
lá para 2022
as empresas que vão ser os negócios você
com massa através
o uso da inteligência artificial é
vender o valor é de 3,9 trilhões de
dólares
a evolução está muito rápido para a
gente nos pergunta que tem feito
empresas sejam mais criativas e mais
inovadoras do que as outras quais são os
fatores que 6 como essa inovação é essa
aceleração combinada com esse avanço
tecnológico
a gente tem feito algumas pesquisas por
exemplo tive recentemente no vale do
silício e eu identifiquei talvez que uma
das empresas que tenham crescido mais
pessoas usaram o ps dos fabricantes
gênero de tiro
todo lugar que eu ia tinha uma mesa de
sinuca em pesquisas que mostram que a
felicidade das pessoas têm uma forte
relação de causa e efeito com a
produtividade e com a criatividade é
importante que a gente reflita o
seguinte a gente passa durante o dia
talvez mais de 50% do nosso tempo
trabalhando
talvez 30% do medo 20% entre o trabalho
com copas falando com um amigo
então se nós fomos infelizes no trabalho
nós vamos fazer muitas vezes 50% tempo
nas nossas vidas
daí a importância de a gente criar
ambientes de trabalho que consigam
trazer felicidade que ele consiga no
sentindo em casa
também este trabalho que temos de
mobilidade que permita a gente tem
acesso a pessoas de outras áreas
observar medo até de outras empresas
como esses espaços de coworking muitas
empresas estão se mudando a espaços de
coworking para facilitar esse
relacionamento com outros tipos de
empresa para que conhecimentos novos
sejam gerados e das coligações
as pessoas moram nos locais de trabalho
é importante então que a gente reflita o
nosso ambiente de trabalho
pelo ponto de vista físico eles nos nos
permite a gente nos sentindo em casa
teve gente ser feliz esse é um dos
fatores fundamentais e pessoa nesse
ambiente de trabalho se a gente tiver
confiança
aí a gente vai longe eu tinha algumas
vezes no japão e uma das coisas que me
chamou mais atenção japoneses é o
respeito que eles têm pelo próximo
o personagem nas empresas e na sociedade
no metrô por exemplo aquela quantidade
enorme de pessoas as pessoas indo assim
empurra umas às outras por exemplo que
um sai para jantar com um grupo de
japoneses
eu notei que ninguém se via a bebida por
exemplo todos servem primeiros outros
depois espero que os outros excessiva é
muito interessante essa confiança é de
você ter certeza que seu corpo não vai
ficar vazio é muito interessante nos
metrôs por exemplo aquelas pessoas
magras máscaras muitas pessoas com massa
não só para não se contaminar mais para
não contaminar outras pessoas não
respeito ea confiança são fundamentais
há pesquisas que indicam que o nível de
confiança de um país tem muita relação
com a riqueza deste país nações que têm
baixo nível de confiança tem a pobreza
isso não é diferente a nossas empresas
dentro das empresas a confiança é um
fator fundamental ea base da motivação
das pessoas
a confiança ela gera essa motivação que
vai gerar o crescimento das pessoas você
confia na outra pessoa você pode
perguntar você pode deixar você pode
contribuir com idéias e isso faz com que
as pessoas e menos emotiva em nossos
relacionamentos no casa familiares com
amigos nas empresas
a confiança é a base da motivação que a
base do crescimento das pessoas a gente
construir um ambiente de confiança ele é
fundamental para a motivação das pessoas
agora a gente costuma organizar nossas
empresas geralmente as operações
realizadas e hierarquicamente é
verticalmente
mas na realidade as empresas não são
organizadas assim porque além da questão
dos processos que permeiam todas essas
organizações dessas reuniões é assim
existe a questão da confiança que faz
com que a gente vai interagir vai buscar
apoio às pessoas que a gente confia e
essas empresas que agora estão se
organizando em redes por exemplo
isso eleva muito mais a inovação
[Música]
projetos ele e metas transparentes
o fluxo de informações livre feedback
constante por exemplo e as pessoas serem
recompensados
não pelo carro mas por suas habilidades
é uma tendência
[Música]
essa questão da organização e diz ela é
fundamental para gerar essa motivação
para que a gente possa crescer e poder
ser mais inovadores
agora o que nos motiva e que motiva as
pessoas todos nós vamos sair em busca de
um propósito nas nossas vidas dizer que
o propósito da vida sempre feliz
eu tenho notado
tem participado de alguns alguns
processos de seleção que hoje em dia as
pessoas estão buscando esse propósito
elas querem saber com propósito daquela
empresa que ela está acidente da tam até
buscar um propósito ou que avaliasse o
seu propósito está alinhado com o
propósito daquela empresa
uma das empresas que eu trabalhei
achei muito interessante o propósito
dessa empresa que era gerar riqueza nas
organizações
naquela organização gera riqueza para o
país e melhora a vida do povo brasileiro
esse tipo de propósito é realmente um
motivador
eu tenho dado minha teoria algumas
startups e a gente vê que as estacas e
vale nascem com a tecnologia por trás da
possibilidade da concretização desses
propósitos e é muito interessante não
propósito ali é a questão financeira vem
também como importância mas o propósito
é muito importante para o crescimento
das empresas eu tive agora semana
passada achei muito interessante num
momento de começar tap cuja cujo
propósito era ajudar os familiares a
cuidar dos seus idosos muito
interessante como é que a tecnologia
pode concretizar esses estes propósitos
em um caso interessante de uma
pesquisadora que conheci outro dia
essa pesquisadora tem um filho o
diabético e eu filho constantemente
tinha crises é aí há o real hospital
soltou vários médicos ela ficava
incomodada quando ia ao médico o médico
perguntar três ou quatro perguntas sobre
o sobre o filho sobre o nível de glicose
é uma só isso e nem perto é muito mais
informação que possa ser utilizado
eu poder tomar as iniciativas ações
necessárias para que o filho não tem
crise
a partir daquele dia ela então
determinada
resolveu então registrar todos os abusos
do seu filho diariamente registavam que
ele comia o que ele fazia medir a
temperatura medir glicose e durante
meses ela continuou fazendo os registros
tinha milhares de dados
ela foi atrás da tecnologia identificou
pessoas que puderem conseguir junto com
elas ao técnicas táticas e técnicas de
inteligência artificial para criar um
modelo preditivo que pudesse então
identificar em que situações o seu filho
poderia ter uma crise esse modelo para
ser usado em várias com várias de
abertos todo mundo então esse é um
exemplo muito interessante de propósito
o propósito nos motiva o propósito faz a
gente crescer mas vamos buscar mais
informações
mas a gente buscar novas tecnologias ela
foi atrás desse conhecimento
e esse crescimento exponencial
ele está vendo aí de startup crescendo
cada vez mais e cada vez mais rápido
ele só é possível devido a essa
facilidade de acesso ao conhecimento
hoje se eu quiser entender se eu quiser
saber quem é o melhor quais são e onde
estão os melhores conhecimentos a
respeito do diabetes
eu entro na web identifico e facilmente
eu me comunico com essas pessoas é o que
a gente chama de inovação aberta à
inovação aberta a gente abrir as
fronteiras da nossa empresa para ter
parceiros onde a gente possa identificar
o que há de melhor e trazer isso pra
trabalhar junto conosco e não faço
aberto ea gente tem a nossa área de
perder não só tendo na empresa
nas áreas de pesquisa e desenvolvimento
no mundo criar associações criar um
ambiente um ecossistema colaborativo
entre estar evento surpresas entre
institutos de pesquisa
investidores em moradoras as operadoras
esse ambiente colaborativo gera então
esse empreendedorismo e mesmo papel
intraempreendedorismo o empreendedorismo
dentro das empresas para que as pessoas
possam criar possam divulgar suas idéias
também o primeiro estágio foi uma
empresa o que me levou a peça empresa
foi uma das crenças que quer que essa
que esse presidente a empresa tia que
era escrito assim as pessoas são
diferentes
nascem diferente tem evoluções diferente
mas todas podem contribuir com o
resultado da empresa
isso me chamou muita atenção e hoje essa
questão da diversidade
a questão do respeito ao outro com essa
confiança apesar do propósito são
fundamentais para que as pessoas e as
empresas possam ser inovadoras possam
criar a questão do do centro está no
cliente isso é fundamental agora é
preciso também dentro das empresas p
método além de tinga tem método a ser
métodos ágeis para quem possa
sistematicamente a identificar quais são
as necessidades dos nossos clientes
transformando essas necessidades em
especificações técnicas de produto e
processo e sendo capaz de projetar
processos que consigam perder fôrma
gerais as características de produto ou
de serviço
a gente precisa testar rapidamente com
ele
bezerros e girar novamente o nosso ciclo
de gestão de maneira mais ativa usando
técnicas de massagens
o método é fundamental para que a gente
possa orientar esse processo de inovação
e como dinheiro no estrangeiro na costa
de forma dentro de si dessa pesquisa que
a gente tem feito junto às empresas
além de ver o seguinte qual que a
fórmula pra gente tenha resultados e os
policiais aquecer negócios produtivos de
negócios competitivos
ele tem uma cultura que promova a
criação do ambiente agradável resposta
ser feliz
aliada a essa questão a confiança
eu sei que confessa vez não muda de uma
hora para a outra
a confiança é uma atitude autônoma a uma
soma de atitudes e que a gente tem um
propósito bem claro bem firme e
transparente
aliada à questão do método que envolve
essa questão na inovação aberta que
permita então essa troca de
conhecimentos com várias empresas no
mundo ea questão do processo claros
potencializado pela tecnologia
eu tenho certeza que esses fatores
contribuem para que a gente possa cada
vez mais negócios e subjetivos que vão
melhorar cada vez mais a qualidade de
vida de todos nós
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]